hey guys what's up I don't wanna end
welcome to my channel and today I just
thought I would update you all on why I
haven't uploaded a video in like a month
it's because I had pneumonia I moved to
America in November and it took me two
months to get my health care card
because health insurance is a weird
really important confusing thing here
and in the amount of time I got sick and
I couldn't go and see your doctor
because it's expensive and weird if you
don't have insurance so then my sickness
turned into pneumonia and it was pretty
brutal those are no it's like basically
a you have fluid in your lungs so I had
a really bad cough that basically meant
I couldn't sleep because I was coughing
all the time
coffee was giving me headaches I was
really drowsy entitled time it was just
like really super awful so I go to the
doctors eventually they took like an
x-ray told me I had pneumonia and I had
to take two straight weeks up a walk
where I was on codeine so I was
basically sleeping for 18 hours day
playing the witness while I was awake
but mostly sleeping I lost a whole bunch
of muscle and weight and just didn't
leave the house at all in that period of
time because coding means you're really
drowsy so I could drive anyway I
couldn't really go anywhere I left like
three times to go to the hospital and
once to go get food so there really
wasn't great so I made a video about it
before and if you like most you probably
know but for those who don't I'm now
working at OGN I am currently in a safe
house room our meeting rooms are all
based off of video games hang I'll show
you
supplies here there's a whole bunch of
cool wallet including I missed Twitter
walls have like sweet bloody handprints
on them safe hostel and my favorite part
oh my god
terrifying the first time that I lived
in America for three months I made a
first impressions video they thought
that I would just kind of follow up on
that and this as well the general San
Francisco things it smells kind of bad
food is crazy overpriced like you can
get grilled cheese sandwiches for like
$6 a haircut is around $80 average in
Australia I wouldn't have paid more than
20 fo because that's outrageous
getting my head dyed is like $300
whereas in Australia probably would have
cost me just over 100 insane and they
also expect a tip we don't tip in
Australia because people earn enough
money but apparently headdresses also
get a tip on top of the insane amount of
money they get for cutting hair it's
crazy
and culturally I think in my first
Australian versus America video I said
that people are nice in America and I
still stand by that I don't know if it's
just a culture adriaen specifically but
the friends that I have here are really
nice to each other
no like complement each other on saying
something funny they like dude those are
really good joke or compliment each
other there's something that someone
else wrote it's like really Cynthia and
friendly and and each other I'm like
what they're wearing all the time
whereas in Australia I feel like we have
a politeness that's just kind of implied
whereas here people are a lot more about
it I guess it's kind of cool
Pizza is so much better here I'm still
eating really really healthy and I go to
gym five days a week so I eat healthy
like a time when I don't eat pizza
American pizza is amazing in comparison
Australian pizza first like cardboard
American pizza is like super cheesy and
has tons of different toppings and a lot
of toppings it's really good
but yeah this is just must be like a
quick update video I should have more
videos coming this week and next week
you guys enjoyed it and I won't see you
next time